mon président il n'y aura plus jamais de
chômage - président il y aura 10 % en
croissance par an - président je referai
de la france la première économie du
monde
voilà le type de promesses que font tous
les candidats et tous les candidats à
l'élection présidentielle
président c'est le poste qui fait envie
à tous les hommes et toutes les femmes
politiques de notre pays
mais ont-ils seulement regarder la fiche
de poste
en effet et qu'on regarde la fiche de
poste l'intitulé exact c'est président
de la république
on parle beaucoup du côté - président
est beaucoup moins du côté république la
république qu'est ce que c'est as tu eu
d'excès un drapeau et céline de national
mais rassurez vous on n'est pas là
aujourd'hui enfin maman craignait non ce
dont j'ai envie de vous parler
aujourd'hui c'est de la devise
républicaine liberté égalité fraternité
une belle devise qui nous vient du
siècle des lumières et dont on a essayé
de faire un rapide bilan aujourd'hui en
la retournant fraternité égalité liberté
fraternité d'abord de quelle fraternité
par le ton des dans notre pays
ils y apprennent neuf millions de
personnes qui vivent sous le seuil de
pauvreté alors même que nous sommes la
cinquième économie la plus puissante du
monde égalité ensuite le cas l égalité
par le ton dès que les 10% les plus
riches possèdent autant que les autres
90% adapté à cette salle si on considère
que vous êtes une centaine est que le
patrimoine de la salle c'est les chaises
c'est comme si je disais aux dix
personnes au premier rang vous avez le
droit à 50 chaises et les quatre-vingt
dix autres vous vous débrouillez avec
les 50 restants pas très logique liberté
ensuite le cai liberté parle-t-on mais
pour subvenir à ses besoins principaux
il faut absolument
un encours dans un marché de l'emploi
avec plus de 9% de chômage fraternité
égalité liberté
on peut retenir l'état de notre devise
républicaine en retenant un chiffre 9 9
comme les neuf millions de personnes qui
vivent sous le seuil de pauvreté
9 comme les neuf dixièmes de la
population qui possède autant que le
dixième le plus riche et 9 comme les 9%
de chômage dans notre pays
le but de la conférence n'est pas de
plomber le moral non on va quand même
essayer de trouver une solution
ce dont j'ai envie de vous parler
aujourd'hui c'est du revenu universel le
revenu universel qu'est ce que c'est
c'est d'abord une définition avec trois
critères trois critères qu'il faut
respecter pour que l'on puisse parler
d'un revenu universel revenu universel
et donc une somme d'argent que l'on
donne mensuellement à tout le monde sans
condition et de manière individuelle si
on parle d'une somme d'argent que l'on
donne seulement jeunes
d'où seulement aux personnes qui aiment
moins de 2000 euros on ne parle pas d'un
revenu universel
si on parle d'une somme d'argent et
qu'en contrepartie de cette somme
d'argent
on doit s'engager à faire des démarches
on ne parle pas d'un revenu universel
si on parle d'une somme d'argent est
calculé à l'échelle d'un foyer ou à
l'échelle d'un couple on ne parle pas
d'un revenu universel
il faut bien avoir ces trois critères qu
on puisse parler de revenu universel
une fois qu'on a cette définition en
tête
on peut se poser plusieurs questions
la première c'est pourquoi pourquoi
vouloir mettre en place un revenu
universel
il ya deux grandes raisons une plutôt
historique et plus contemporaine au
niveau de l'arrêt vous historique
car il faut savoir que même si dans le
débat actuel on nous parle du des du
revenu universel comme une idée neuve
ça fait plusieurs siècles que des gens
ils réfléchissent la raison historique
un des premiers penseurs avoir parlé du
revenu universel
c'était thomas spain au xviiie siècle et
l'idée c'est de lutter contre la
pauvreté et de répartir les richesses
avec une idée toute simple de dire que
la terre nous en avons tous hérité elle
nous appartient à tous certains s'en
sont accaparés des boues résultat tout
le monde n'a pas un lopin de terre pour
pouvoir subvenir à ses besoins
principaux donc en contrepartie il
souhaitait mettre en place une dotation
inconditionnelle
la raison plus contemporaines qui fait
que le débat ressurgit actuellement
c'est que le revenu universel pourrait
être une réponse à l'évolution du monde
de l'emploi faut savoir qu'avec
l'automatisation et la numérisation
il ya beaucoup d'emplois qui
disparaissent les y en a aussi qui sont
créés en face tout le débat actuel c'est
de savoir est ce qu un droit plus qui
seront créés ou est y en aura plus qui
vont disparaître
donc on va arrêter le débat aujourd'hui
et je vais vous donner la réponse
on n'en sait rien du tout la seule chose
qu'on sait c'est que les emplois qui
sont recréés maintenant sont beaucoup
moins stable que les emplois d'hier là
où avant on pouvait rester 40 ans dans
la même entreprise
maintenant non seulement ne restent pas
40 ans dans la même entreprise mais même
indirecte d'une journée on peut avoir
plusieurs activités
le revenu universel serait donc en
quelque sorte un filet de sécurité pour
un monde de l'emploi moins linéaire une
première question pourquoi la deuxième
qui nous vient à l'esprit c'est combien
à combien se situe reste universel donc
il ya beaucoup de propositions qu'ils
ont formulés mais en général les
montants vont du niveau du rsa un peu
plus de 500 euros par mois au niveau du
smic
un peu moins de 1200 euros par mois en
passant par le niveau du seuil de bord
le niveau du seuil de pauvreté en france
il est mille euros par mois pour une
personne seule
comment il est calculé c'est définition
internationale c'est 60% du revenu
médian
le revenu médian qu'est ce que c'est ces
revenus qui sépare la population en 2
50% gagnent moins 50% gagner plus en
france le revenu médian est de 1666
euros donc 60% de 1666 euros 1000 euros
pourquoi on calcule la pauvreté de cette
manière là c'est parce qu'on est
toujours port ont paré à la société dans
laquelle on vit
on s'aperçoit qu'en france avec 1000
euros on va pouvoir s'en sortir mais ça
peut être difficile alors que dans un
pays en développement avec la même somme
ça serait facile et on pourrait même
être considérée comme riche donc
pourquoi
combien la troisième question qu'on peut
se poser c'est comment
comment mettre 100 places comment le
financer il ya trois grandes familles de
financement la première famille c'est
l'autofinancement l'idée c'est de se
dire si on met en place un revenu
universel hauteur du seuil de pauvreté
le rsa n'a plus de raison d'être
donc les sommes qui sont actuellement
affectées au financement du rsa pourrait
être réaffectée au financement de revenu
universel
la deuxième famille de financement de
revenu universel c'est des taxes les
taxes qui vont souvent être en relation
avec la raison philosophique pour
laquelle on souhaite mettre en place le
revenu universel
si on n'est plus dans une logique de
lutte contre la pauvreté et de
répartition des richesses
on va avoir tendance à vouloir taxer les
revenus ou le patrimoine d'induction
n'est plus dans une logique de s'adapter
au mans de l'emploi on va être plus dans
une logique de vouloir taxer les
entreprises ou les robots et la dernière
source de financement au niveau du rôle
universel
il cite une source dont on parle
beaucoup moins dans le débat c'est la
création monétaire
il faut savoir qu'actuellement pour
stimuler l'économie les banques
centrales créent de toutes pièces de
l'argent qu'elle injecte dans le système
et on peut se poser la question de
pourquoi donner certains gens aux
banques
plutôt que de le donner directement aux
citoyens ce qu'il faut bien retenir avec
le revenu ni l'a fait c'est que c'est un
concept avec des concrétisations
différentes
on voit souvent comme monsieur universel
dans mon entourage mais je ne suis pas
d'accord avec tout les revenu universel
le revenu universel
c'est un concept que je comprends il ya
des concrétisations avec lesquels je
suis d'accord et des concrétisations
avec lesquels je ne suis pas d'accord
on a donc une devise républicaine en
faillite est un concept avec le multiple
concrétisation possible qu'est ce que ça
donnerait si on réunissait ces deux
idées ça donnerait le rêve
notre rêve rêve que nous avons fait avec
romain avec lequel nous formons les
écolos du mali sq le rêve signifie
revenus émancipateur pour vivre épanouie
on va reprendre la devise de la
république pour définir un peu mieux à
quoi ressemblerait notre revenu
universel idr fraternité d'abord pour
nous le revenu universel
l'idéal serait fixé au niveau du seuil
de pauvreté
cela nous permettrait au passage de
répondre à l'article 25 de la
déclaration universelle des droits de
l'homme
que dit cet article 25 de la déclaration
universelle des droits de l'homme il dit
que toute personne a droit à un niveau
de vie suffisant pour pouvoir subvenir à
ses besoins principaux qui sont de se
nourrir de se vêtir et de se loger
article 25 de la déclaration universelle
des droits de l'homme que nous avons
signé et que nous ne respectons pas
actuelle égalité
pour nous le revenu universel doit être
un outil de redistribution avec
notamment des taxes des fleuristes qui
permet à financer le revenu universel
on ne dit pas qu'il n'y aurait pas de
simplifier
a sion forcément qui auraient des
oeuvres qui serait amené à disparaître
mais trop souvent dans le débat actuel
le revenu universel est vue comme un
outil de simplification pour nous ça
doit aussi être un outil de registre et
du ce et liberté enfin de quelle liberté
la liberté donnerait ce revenu universel
ce rêve ce rêve permettrait de dire non
la capacité de dire non c'est une
capacité très importante pour pouvoir
choisir sa vie pouvoir dire non ça
pourrait permettre aux salariés de
négocier de meilleures conditions de
travail
donc de travailler mieux
de la même manière certains pour exposé
ir ponctuellement de travailler moins
avec période de la vie où ils ont envie
d'élever un enfant de se former le
lancer une activité
travailler moins travailler mieux on
peut même aller jusqu'à se poser la
question
2 qu'est ce que le travail c'est pour ça
qu'on m'a choisi d'illustrer la liberté
avec les abeilles pour l'instant au
niveau des abeilles avec le pib qui est
notre seul indicateur pour mesurer
l'activité ce qui comptait dans le pib
pour les abeilles
c'est le miel qu'elles produisent et que
l'on vend alors qu'on sait bien que la
vraie valeur ajoutée des abeilles c'est
la pollinisation qu'elles font et qui
permet à toutes les fleurs et tous les
fruits de se développer
de la même manière appliquée aux êtres
humains on peut se poser la question est
notre valeur ajoutée est seulement la
valeur qu'ils créent dans une entreprise
au niveau monétaire
où est la valeur ajoutée concret c'est
pas de la même manière cette
pollinisation le fait toutes nos
relations sociales qui nous permettent à
chacun de nous épanouir et de faire
société
notre rêve revenus émancipateur pour
vivre et pas nous et s'il ya un mot à
retenir dans cette définition
c'est le côté émancipateur pour nous la
mise en place de ce revenu
l'universel idéal serait un vrai
changement de paradigme pour l'instant
on est dans une société où tout le monde
se déroule et on vient et v ce qui
arrive le moins au risque c
ces personnes massot stigmatiser voir
soit traitée d'assister par d'autres
personnes alors que si on met en place
un revenu universel on change tout à
fait la logique on va faire confiance à
tout le monde et ceux qui s'en sortent
le mieux économiquement vont autofinancé
leur revenu universel voir vont financer
d'autres vous l'avez compris notre rêve
et on espère que ça deviendra nous votre
c'est de redonner un peu de réalité à
notre devise républicaine fraternité
égalité liberté et à ce moment là
seulement à ce moment là on pourra
conclure nos discours en disant vive la
république et vive la france
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]